what does the silent majority need to
stop being silent mean
yes this is something a very keen people
take into account i'm fed up of hearing
about the silent majority
um i've heard about it all my life i'm
sure you have people say well a silent
majority don't believe that i've always
said but why are they silent
what's the problem and if they're a
majority even more so what
that's it makes no sense to me
um the thing that we've been told in
recent years
is the silent majority only
stops being silent at elections when it
silently votes
in ways that surprise the rest of the
country which it seems
is is kind of kind of true right yeah
the obvious
example is um a brexit vote in 2016 and
the trump vote in 2016.
and uh uh then they said well now we've
heard from the silent majority
and then that silent majority is said to
be totally you know deplorable and uh
um and it should be you know somehow
expunged in the democratic process
because it doesn't know what it's doing
says the losing minority um
but uh yeah i don't understand
why it should be the case that people
only make themselves heard
at the ballot box once every four years
or something like that
um so what i think is happening is back
to
where we started actually is that a very
small number of
very valuable people are making all of
the weather
uh and i don't see why they should and
the only reason they
they do is because they manage to
intimidate
the majority into going along with
things that we don't have to go along
with
i just i refuse and i think everyone
else should
to go along with any more of the crap i
strongly urge people to stop going along
with the crap now what does that mean
it means for instance if you
work in a company and you are told that
you're going to have a day where you've
all got to think about racism
you either say no or you say
what is it you're trying to make us
learn
and what are you trying to make us
conclude and are you right
in that so i published a little while
ago a
letter had been leaked from the nhs
trust where this nhs trust chief in
birmingham
told everyone working for her what books
to read
and i think that the people working for
her and with her should not just laugh
at her
or say oh my gosh i didn't rise how
racist i am in the nhs trust in
birmingham i had no idea that the nhs
trust in birmingham was the place where
the fourth reich was going to re-emerge
why we must stop it
they don't just do that they say no
no we're not going to spend the rest of
our lives being
told what to read and told what to
think and told what to say and told how
to dance and
everything else no we're not going to do
it
and if if the so-called silent majority
did that then we would be so much
further forward as a society
and what's more we can do it in a
perfectly reasonable way
i i've had experience a lot in recent
weeks i'm sure you have
wanting to have conversations about you
know by the way you always told oh we
just want to have the conversation about
this no you don't you want to lecture
people
but i'd be very happy to have
conversations about colonialism and
slavery and racism and the existence of
racism throughout history
across all races and i'm very happy to
have all those conversations
but actually the people who say they
want those conversations don't want the
conversations they just want to win
what they want is to wear a unitard
spandex khaki colored sort of
one-piece thing and to tell you that
you're racist and put their paypal
address up on the board that's what they
wanted yeah yeah
they want to be the kim young owner of
anti-racism
and um to tell everyone
uh um what to believe and
uh i don't think that's uh uh i'm not
going along with that
so i i don't think other people should
either
[Music]